- Welcome to the last talk of the day,
5:30 on a Tuesday, why not?
Although it's Vegas so you
guys probably have like
two dinners and like six happy hours
between now and whenever you go home.
Anyway, my name is Sean Falconer.
- And my name is Cal Rueb.
- And welcome, this is, well,
essentially we're gonna be talking about
how to go from AI Agent Demos
to essentially production.
I think a challenge that many,
many businesses face today.
So first off, how many people here,
just put your hands up, have
built some sort of AI demo?
You know, maybe it's a single
shot prompt, RAG, Agent.
All right, keep your hands up.
And then how many of you
have made those demos
turn into production use cases?
Anybody?
Yep, a few. Great.
So this is one of the challenges
and of course there could
be many, many reasons why
you haven't been able to move
those demos into production.
Maybe the demo is never designed
to be a production use
case to start off with.
But what we're gonna talk a
little bit about today is,
our experience working
with a number of customers
across Confluent as well
as Anthropic and some of
our experience where we
see customers getting stuck
with moving essentially those types of
demos and POCs into production.
And you know, clearly, AI is powering
a lot of new experiences.
We just crossed through the third year
anniversary of Check EPT.
There's been such an
explosion of technology.
Last time I was at
re:Invent was two years ago.
I walk around the expo floor today
and it's unrecognizable to
where it was two years ago
because a lot of those
companies either didn't exist
or they're very much in their
infancy a couple years ago.
Everything's about AI right
now, and it has transformed,
I think, a lot of how we
think about doing our jobs.
If we're engineers, we're
probably using some sort of AI
assistive coding tool,
Claude Code for example.
Or you know, if we're generating content,
we're probably using some sort of AI-based
tool to help us do that.
We're relying more and
more on these systems.
Yet at the same time,
a lot of companies are
still struggling for
"Where is the ROI for
my particular use case?"
or "I wanna solve this problem,
how do I solve this problem?"
And, "I can't get there.
I'm still struggling to essentially
bring that stuff into production."
And while all this is going on,
a lot of people believe also
that like Agents are
the future of software.
You know, you hear of lots
of proclamations like,
"SaaS is dead, it's all about Agents."
And regardless of the
metrics that you look at,
whether it's, you know, this chart
that's predicting the Agent market being
50 billion by the year 2030,
or Gartner reporting that
they think that by 2028,
33% of all software will have
some sort of Agent baked into it.
You know, it's always hard
to make predictions in technology.
We tend to overestimate in the short term
and underestimate in the long term,
but, even if you only
believe some of this stuff,
it's directionally correct,
it's of course something that we all need
to be paying attention to
when we work in technology
and we're trying to all
figure this out right now.
And I think the dream or the
promise of Agents is amazing.
Like the fact that we
could have some sort of
dynamic autonomous system
that's doing work on our behalf.
Everybody gets like, you know,
an intern in their pocket,
really like the smartest
intern that's possible
with almost perfect recall.
That's amazing.
So if we can turn that
dream on for our businesses
to solve all kinds of different use cases,
of course we wanna be able to do that.
Now, fundamentally what is
different about, you know,
these types of models,
and broadly speaking,
when we look at AI,
there's been sort of two
different eras or waves.
We've had purpose-built models,
and then now we have foundation models
or Generative AI, Large Language Models,
however you wanna kinda term it.
And one isn't necessarily a
replacement for the other,
but there are key
characteristic differences
between these kind of two different eras
that's important to understand.
So with purpose-built
models, or predictive AI,
some people might call this,
this is kind of like
the AI that I grew up on
and was trained in and was a researcher in
for a number of years.
The way that you build
these models typically
is you start with your data.
So you start with your business data
and you go through this
batch offline process
of feature extraction,
feature engineering,
you train your model, you test that model.
Once you're happy with
it, you can deploy it
and you start using it
within your application.
And these have served us well for decades
and will continue to serve us
well for decades from here.
But the sort of limitation of these models
is that they're purpose built.
So they're kind of singular purpose.
Like once I've gone ahead
and I've trained my fraud detection model,
I can't just start doing
image classification with it.
I need to go through essentially
a different training process,
maybe even use a different type of model,
probably different features
to go and train that image
classification model.
So they're limited in
terms of their reusability,
but the advantage of the models
is they know a lot about you
because they were trained on your data,
and they were trained to
solve a specific task.
So they have a representation
of essentially your business
baked into the weights of that model.
And foundation models
can have an opposite set
of characteristics where
they are these massive models
that are trained essentially on, you know,
everything publicly available
and only a handful of
companies in the world
have the resources and knowledge
how to actually construct these models.
And they packaged them up in a nice API
that anybody who knows how to call an API
can essentially leverage the model.
They don't need to know anything about
sort of how the model was constructed
or the guts of the model to use it.
And this has democratized access to AI
and I think led in many ways
this explosion of interest
and people building software
that leverages AI today.
And the other amazing thing is
that they can be used for
infinitely many things.
I can use the same model for
many, many different use cases.
But the limitation of the models is that
as smart as they are
about public information,
and general information,
they're kind of dumb when it comes
to essentially your business information
'cause they lack that context.
They weren't actually
trained on your customer data
or on the data within your business.
So you have to give them that information.
So how do you do that?
Well typically that
happens during this process
of prompt time assembly.
So, when I'm about to
call the API to the model,
I need to go and gather essentially
whatever additional data
that I need to sort of
to give to the model
so that it understands what the task is
and they can accomplish this goal.
And in an enterprise scenario,
this is kind of easier
said than done because
enterprises have data all over the place.
You might have thousands
of different databases.
You have SaaS locations,
SaaS applications where
your data might be located,
you have APIs, all these things.
And this has been these data
silos and data fragmentation,
and just understanding where your data is,
has been a problem in
businesses for decades now.
And AI is really just the
next sort of forcing function
for people to think about deeply
what their AI or their data strategy is,
'cause fundamentally it's hard to have
an AI strategy without a data strategy.
'Cause if your data's a mess, you know,
slapping a model on top of it
doesn't really solve that mess.
So how do you essentially do that?
And a lot of this essentially
is grounded in this concept
of context engineering.
I'm gonna hand this off to
Cal to talk a little bit about
how we've evolved essentially
beyond the prompt.
- All right, thank you.
So I joined Anthropic about two years ago
to help start a team
that we call Applied AI
and it's Applied AI's mission and goal
to help our customers build great products
and features on top of Claude.
So when I first showed up at Anthropic,
I was meeting with companies
from AI native startups
to large banks, meeting
with their products teams,
their engineering teams,
figuring out what they're trying to build
and seeing if we can do it with Claude,
if Claude can solve their problems.
On top of that, everyone
on the Applied AI team
to make sure we're not just
people that talk to customers
but don't actually do the work,
everyone on the Applied AI team
also contributes to Anthropics products.
And so when Claude Code
was still an internal tool,
I discovered it and really
fell in love with it
and got to know Kat
and Boris and the team,
and kind of joined that team
as like a second job almost.
And so, most of the
system prompt, the tools,
all the kind of AI engineering
that powers Claude Code
I wrote or worked on in some way.
And so between those things
I've had a very nice,
I've had kind of the privilege
to have a front row seat
into how we build on top of these models
and get things into production,
and how this has evolved.
So when I joined Anthropic
in January of 2024,
we had a model called Claude 2.1.
Has anyone here ever use Claude 2.1?
Okay, no one. That doesn't
surprise me too much.
Claude 2.1 was not the
best model in the world.
There were some cool things about it.
It was on AWS Bedrock,
something that our customers
still really appreciate
about Claude today,
and additionally it had a very large
context window of 200,000 tokens,
which many of the other
players in the space
kind of topped out at
about 32,000 or 64,000.
So we had a few customers
but things weren't crazy.
Then we released Opus 3.
Has anyone here used Opus 3?
Maybe? One, all right.
Opus 3 when we released
it was by many measures
the best model in the world
and it really put us on the map
and kind of set us off on
this awesome trajectory.
One thing we believe at Anthropic
is we believe we are on this path to build
better and better models
and we think this is
gonna happen very rapidly.
And we also believe that
this rapid improvement in AI
will have transformational effects
on society and the world and how we work.
And we do a lot of work to study this
and research it and get ahead of it.
But more practically, as the
models have gotten better,
and as continue to get better,
the way we build on top of
these models has evolved.
So when I joined Anthropic and
I was meeting with customers
in the Claude 2.1 days
and the Claude 3 days,
most of the things people were building,
not super ambitious,
were what we might call
kind of single turn prompts.
Things like, "Hey I need to classify
a whole bunch of product reviews,"
or "I need to write a
first draft of an email."
Or, we did a lot of this, "Here's
three help center articles
and a customer question,
can you draft a response?"
A lot of like Q&A chatbot sort of stuff.
The models started to get a little better
and people started to get more ambitious
about what can we build
on top of these LMs,
and we transitioned into
what we call Workflows.
So one thing you could think about doing
is you have your single prompts
and a bunch of instructions.
You could just say,
"Okay, I'll just put more
in my single prompt and have it do more
interesting complex things."
Well in practice that
doesn't work very well.
The model can, you know,
maybe only reliably follow
so many instructions at once.
And so how do we build something
that's more interesting
and rich that we can't get
done in a single prompt?
Well we try to decompose
this task and split it up
and chain multiple prompts together
and maybe mix in some deterministic logic
to get something more interesting and rich
than we could have in our kind
of single turn architecture.
And so if you have used
AI features and products,
even today, if you were
to peer under the hood,
probably a lot of that stuff
is powered by Workflows.
Now Workflows in practice
have two problems.
One of them is that Workflows
are really only as good
as kind of all the edge cases
that you've kind of planned for, right?
Like we have kind of this
predetermined set of things
that this Workflow can do,
and that doesn't work very
well for open-ended tasks.
So if you're trying to build an AI system
that can just do day-to-day
software engineering for you,
very hard to build that in a Workflow.
I've met with customers and seen customers
that have Workflows that are
made up of 50 different prompts
and it can be very challenging
to kind of manage this
and keep this under control.
The other thing that is tricky
about building as a Workflow
is that if something goes wrong
in the middle of this Workflow,
you're on LLM call two,
and something, I don't
know, unexpected happens,
the LM makes a mistake
or something like that,
it is very hard to build
any sort of error correction
or the Workflow notices
something went wrong
and can't kind of self correct.
And so, starting late last
year, and certainly this year,
we have moved into, for many problems,
building on top of a
different architecture.
At Anthropic, this is what we call Agents.
And with an Agents, in many
ways it is much more simple,
but we take our LLM, we give
it a set of instructions,
and we give it a set of tools
and some sort of open-ended task
and we basically say to
the LM, "Work on this task,
call these tools as much as you want.
Let me know when you're done."
And this helps with our open-ended problem
'cause we don't have to
code for everything ourself.
We let the Agent kind of figure
the problem out on its own,
we trust it to do it,
we're giving it agency.
And on top of that, if things
go wrong, I don't know,
the model calls a tool and
it gets back a response
that it didn't expect or
it gets back an error,
the model can see that and react to it
and adjust its course and try again.
And so it gives you a lot
more of this reliability
and you can build more
rich, robust kind of
products and applications
on top of this architecture.
And so at Anthropic we see
both of these kind of setups
in production today, they're
good at different times.
We have Workflows when we have
more narrow, very repeatable,
maybe we wanna mix in a little
deterministic logic tasks,
and then we use our
Agents when we're building
more kind of open-ended,
broad, sort of, I dunno,
working on those sort of problems
and maybe we have a set of
tools and things can go wrong,
and we're trusting the model
to deal with more ambiguity.
- Great, thank you.
So as we've evolved from
sort of this, you know,
single call shot prompting
into Agents and Workflows,
this has also I think,
represented an important shift
in how we think about engineering,
and a shift in sort of
architecting software.
So with traditional software
we essentially code the
business logic of the software
using precise logic and rules.
You know, we're writing
essentially that code.
I click on a button, something
happens that has been
predetermined and essentially
baked into the software.
But with AI systems, what we're doing is,
since we're relying on
these probabilistic models
to make certain dynamic decisions,
we're essentially steering
the model with the data
and the context that
we feed into the model.
So in a lot of ways,
the business logic essentially
becomes a output of the data
and the context that we're
feeding into the model.
And it's a shift, represents a shift,
where instead of software
necessarily being
precise logic and rules,
your data pipeline in a lot of ways,
becomes kind of your software application.
And the same change is kind of happening
in the world of testing where,
with traditional software,
we use unit tests, we use system tests,
where we can deterministically
test the software,
but now we're moving
in this world of evals
where we're using probabilistic tests
against the AI systems.
And with unit tests we
don't necessarily need
to test our software using a
real data because essentially
the same input's gonna
generate same output,
it can be deterministically run.
If the unit has passed, we
have some level of confidence
that the software is
going to run as expected
once we put it into production.
With AI systems, it's
hard to do that without
some representation of the real data
because the data is
such an important input
to orchestrate or sort
of steering the model
in a particular direction.
So we need to be able
to essentially evaluate
in batch offline using some
representation of the real data,
but we also need to be observing
these sort of in real time
and also continually
evaluating the AI system
against a real reflection of the data
to have some sense that, or of
reliability of the AI system.
So with traditional software,
we lived in a world of iterating on code,
and with AI systems we're
essentially moving in the world
where we're iterating
on data all the time.
We need to iterate, sort of
process, reprocess the data,
and test and eval and get to a place
where we have some level of confidence
this AI system's gonna do
what we expect it to do.
And, talk more about sort of
all the components of this,
like why context matters,
what are all the elements
of context engineering,
I'll pass this back to Cal.
- Okay, so remember when
we were doing single turn?
Back then, we weren't really,
you know, the models weren't very smart
and we weren't quite,
we hadn't quite figured things out.
And so I would call this the
era of prompt engineering.
Last year when I was here at re:Invent,
I had a whole kind of talk
where I was talking about
prompt engineering best practices.
And, I don't know, prompt
engineering was all about
"Okay, you know, the
model's not very smart
so I gotta think about
how exactly do I craft
my instructions in a way where I get
something useful outta the
model on the other side?"
There are all these tips and tricks like,
"Oh how many examples should I use?"
And "Oh, if I'm using anthropic models
I better wrap everything in XML tags.
I think that'll make the
model work a little better."
And so, when you were kind of building
on top of single turn prompts,
what you're thinking about was,
"Okay, how do I kind of, what
do I put in my system prompt?
What do I put in my user message?"
There was a time at Anthropic where like
one of the pro-prompt engineering tips was
"Never use the system
prompt for anything,"
because Claude was
anecdotally a little better
at instruction following if
it was in the user message.
And so there's this, all
these kind of little tricks
that people would, you know,
kind of think about and and
try to iterate on and test.
Now, we are in kind of the Agentic world
and so we have moved on
from prompt engineering
to what we call context engineering,
and we kind of think of this as a more
broad and interesting problem.
Why?
Well we have our system prompt
and user message just like before,
but we have other things
that we wanna think about.
Now we have our tools and if
we wanna maybe give our Agent
access to documents and
other pieces of text,
how do we do that?
And then remember, the Agent
is the LM running in a loop.
So it's not just one single
API called to the LM,
it's going to be calling
the LM, it does something,
you go do something else, then
you give it back to the LM,
and it's running a loop
and going and going, going.
So we have the assistant
message, what does the Agent say?
And we're gonna have all of
our tool calls and results
and this is gonna build up over time.
And then, maybe to mix things up,
we wanna add some new
tools, some new documents.
And so the problem space,
what we need to think about and work on
when we're building Agents,
putting them into production,
a little more interesting,
a little more fun
than prompt engineering in my opinion.
So that's what I'm gonna be talking about.
So prompt engineering, back in the day,
models weren't super smart.
They were very, very sensitive to exactly
how you phrase things and worded things.
What words will get me
the absolute best output?
Context engineering much
more about just managing
this whole information environment.
What tokens, what am I gonna
present to my Agent and when?
How am I going to do it?
What is the optimal
configuration of context
to get my desired behavior
out of this system?
I've said context a few times,
it's worth mentioning
that when I say context,
I mean the context window.
So all LMs, whether you're using
Claude or ChatGPT or Gemini,
they have this context window limit
and this is actually
enforced at the API level,
but there's only so much
text or so many words
you can pour into the LM
and get a response back.
And it's not that we don't
know how to do the math
where if you gave us, you
know, 10 million tokens,
we wouldn't know how to process it.
It's more about that
the LM, at some point,
we start to see like diminishing returns
or if you pour too much text into the LM,
it starts to get confused
and do a bad job.
So we have to like cut,
set some thresholds,
where we think it's an
appropriate time to just say,
"Hey you shouldn't be passing
any more tokens to this model."
There's this idea of
context rot, which is,
okay we have all these tokens,
all this text that we
could put into the model.
I kind of hinted at this earlier,
which is we could take
all these instructions
and put them into the,
(stumbles over words)
give it to the model.
We could take a whole bunch of documents
and give it to the model.
What we find is in most use cases,
if you just start dumping text in there,
the model tends to do a little worse
at whatever you're gonna ask it to do.
And so, even before you hit
this context window limit,
you wanna be mindful of, okay,
when my Agent is working,
when it's calling Tools
and getting responses back,
the initial instructions,
I don't wanna lot of extra junk in there
because it's probably gonna
be impacting performance.
There's a company called Chroma,
they did a very nice technical
report, it's a blog post,
look it up, they write all about this,
and they actually kind of break it down
and talk about different
ways that this can fail.
The other reason you're gonna
want to think about context,
especially when you're building Agents,
remember I said that an Agent
is the LM running in a loop,
multiple calls over and over again,
is if you build your
Agent in the right way
and you're thinking about context,
you can take advantage of
things like prompt caching.
The idea with prompt caching is
if you make an API call to an LLM,
and then you make another
call and there's some sort of
fixed prefix like the text didn't change
from one API call to the next,
Anthropic can cache it behind the scenes
and then we can pass on a very nice
little cost discount to you
as well as you benefit from some latency
because we don't have to process
these input tokens again.
And so if you are building with
context engineering in mind,
you can take advantage of these things.
And so when we talk about
context engineering,
we're really trying to kind of
move three different levers.
One of 'em is very practical and boring.
It's the fact that our
API will only let you pass
so much text into it at once.
So we need to think about,
okay, how are we gonna deal
with this context window limit
and get around that and
still get our system
to do cool things?
We can reduce context rot,
which is this idea of
even after we've kind of,
when we are giving stuff to the model,
can we make sure the tokens
that we're showing it
are useful and we're not hurting
our accuracy in some way?
And then finally,
if we do this right and we
are mindful of prompt caching,
we get some nice cost and latency benefits
and so we do all these
things in our own products
when we're building Claude Code
and we advise our customers
to do this as well.
What are some other
things we can think about
when we're doing context engineering?
Well, we have our system prompts,
the instructions that we're
gonna give the Agent, the model.
We have our tools, okay?
What is our Agent gonna be able to do?
How can it interact with the world
and pull more information
in and change things?
We have data retrieval, which
we're gonna talk about a lot,
which is, okay, this Agent
is only gonna be as useful
as kind of the information that
wasn't pre-trained into it.
How do we pull things
in about the business,
about the problem, about the customer,
so that it can make smart decisions?
And then I'll talk a little bit about
long horizon optimizations.
If we're building an Agent that might work
for minutes or hours or days,
we're gonna have to do some fancy stuff
to get around some more
practical limitations
like the context window
which is going to fill up.
So let's start with the system prompts.
And when we talk about prompting today,
when I'm meeting with customers
and talking about prompting,
it's less about, okay,
should I format my prompt
as JSON or markdown, or, "Cal,
should I be using XML tags
and where should I be doing it?"
We're at a point where
we've done so much work
to make the model steerable
that the little tips and tricks
around XML tags don't matter so much.
So when people ask me,
"Hey Cal, what's like
your best prompting tip?"
I always tell them that
the best tip I have
when you're writing a prompt for an LM
is you should take that prompt
and imagine you are
giving it to your friend
or your coworker that doesn't
know what you're working on
and you say to them,
"Hey, with this prompt,
with these instructions, would
you be able to do this task?"
And if they say yes, then
probably the LM can do it too.
And if they say, "No,
I'm a little confused,
I don't really know what
you're asking me for,"
probably the LM is confused as well.
My team, what we do is
we go meet with customers
and very often a customer
will say something like,
"Eh, we tried Claude,
but like I don't know,
it didn't really work that well.
I don't think we wanna
use it in production."
And always what we'll say back is like,
"Oh okay, that's fine.
But can we take a look at the prompts?
We might be able to help."
And nine times outta 10 when
we go and look at the prompts,
there's something confusing
in the instructions
and we can go in and point it out
and clean it up and fix it,
put that into production,
and all of a sudden Claude works well.
And so there's kind of two failure modes,
even if you write good instructions,
where things can go wrong.
So, one example of this is I
was working with a customer
and was building a Customer Support Agent,
and what they did at the very
start in their kind of POC
is they took the standard
operating procedure, the SOP,
that they give their human Support Agents
when they onboard, when
they start on the first day.
It's about a 32-page PDF,
they copy pasted it into the prompts
and then they came to me and said,
"Hey, this isn't working very well."
(audience chuckles)
And I was like, "Oh my god."
And so, this is where
you can get too specific.
If your prompt starts to look
like something on the left
where you have like this
complicated Workflow,
and especially if you have all
of these if/else statements,
you have this very complicated
chain of instructions
that goes on and on and on,
especially for thousands
and thousands of tokens,
you're gonna overwhelm the model.
It's not gonna be able
to do this very well.
And there's techniques and
ways to get around this,
but this is probably not what
your prompt should look like.
On the other side, you can
fail by being too vague,
and this is what I talked about earlier.
You give the prompt to your
friend and they're like,
"I don't know what you're talking about.
I don't know how I would
do this task myself
with these instructions."
And so when we think about prompting,
we're kind of trying to
get into what we call
this Goldilocks zone where have
just the right amount of details
but we're leaving things open-ended
and letting the model
do what it does best,
which is deal with nuance.
We're not trying to
hard code in a Workflow,
we're trying to give agency to the model
so it can kind of work.
And we want to just be
telling the model, you know,
the general way of how it's
gonna solve this problem
and then the non-negotiable things
that it absolutely must do
or absolutely shouldn't do.
And then everything else,
we should try to let it
figure out on its own.
So it can be too prescriptive.
Signs of that is if we have a
whole bunch of if/else logic,
we have these very complex
and brutal instructions,
and we're trying to encode
every single possible scenario
into the instructions.
And then of course,
we can fail on the other side like I said.
That's the system prompt.
Okay, what about tool design?
So we have our instructions
in the system prompts,
but we're also going to give our Agent
1, 2, 10, 50 different tools?
How do we do that well?
Well, we wanna remember that the tools,
when we give a tool to the model,
we should just think of that
as additional prompting.
What happens behind the
scenes when you make
an API call to Anthropic and
you pass the tools array,
we take that tools array,
we actually just plop it at
the top of the system prompt
and it says something like,
"Hey Claude, here's
the tools you can use."
And Claude's been trained
to kind of know what to do from there.
But when you're defining these tools
and passing 'em in the API,
you gotta remember that those definitions
are going straight to the model.
It is seeing what you are typing in there.
And so there's some things we can do here
to make sure that we do well.
So one, is we want just
simple accurate names,
search customers.
We don't want something that's
just like, I don't know,
X, Y, Z, 1, 2, 3.
We want detailed and
well-formed descriptions
and we can do things in our descriptions.
Think of it like more prompting.
We can do things in our
descriptions like provide examples,
like here are good times to use this tool
and here are bad times to use this tool.
When I was working on Claude Code,
I was very often not messing
with our system prompts
but I was spending most of
my time in tool descriptions
tweaking kind of the prompting
and instructions there.
One failure mode that
can definitely happen
when you're building an Agent
that's more general purpose
and can do a lot of
things is in claude.ai,
which is our kind of chatbot tool
that we sell to enterprises.
We had one team that was off building
a web search feature at some point.
They had built this tool that
was something like Search Web,
and meanwhile another
team was building out
our Google Drive integration,
so they had built this search drive tool.
And both of these things
were working very well
and we shipped these
at around the same time
and we kind of put 'em in, you know,
the model now has the search web tool
and the search drive
tool, and all of a sudden,
the model kind of, there wasn't
very good prompting here,
and so the model was confused about
when to use which tool and when.
What information would be
hiding behind a Google Drive
and what would be behind the web.
And so the model would
be searching for things
in Google Drive where clearly
it should be using the web and vice versa.
And so if our tools, the
names and descriptions,
especially on searches where
we've ran into this the most,
are too similar,
you can get into trouble
and confuse the model.
Okay, data retrieval paradigm shifts.
So, back in the day back
when we were building
single term prompts and and Workflows,
the way you would give the
model information about things
it wouldn't know about because
it wasn't trained on it,
it wasn't in the pre-training set,
was you do this thing called RAG:
Retrieve Augmented Generation.
The basic idea is here,
is you have a step before you call the LM
where you go try to grab all
the potentially useful information
and then you give it
to the LM and you say,
"Here's the information.
Try to do, I dunno, try to
answer this question. Good luck."
RAG has a problem, which is,
if you fail the retrieval,
if you do a bad job at retrieval,
there's nothing the LM
can really do about it.
If you give it kind of junk data,
it can't really recover out of it.
Agents solve this problem
because we can give
the Agent a search tool
and the Agent can write
a query to run a search,
get some results back and think,
"Oh weird, I didn't get what
I wanted, let me try again."
So that sort of like I
talked about earlier,
the ability to kind of recover
out of errors in bad states.
And so in an Agentic setup
when we're context engineering,
we're always thinking about,
"Okay, what do I wanna
preload into my Agent?
What do I want to always be there?"
Probably the instructions and the tools
and what information
can I kind of hide away
and tuck away behind my tools
and the Agent can go grab it
only if it really needs it?
So in Claude Code for
instance, if you use this tool,
we have something called Claude.md.
This is like a special
markdown file that is optional,
but we let our developers basically
put in additional like
information and instructions
and preferences that are unique to them
about how they want Claude Code to behave
and you know, what they
want it to know about
themselves or the code base.
And so something like that,
we preload no matter what.
When the Agent starts,
we just look in the
current working directory
for a Claude.md file.
If it's there we put
it in the system prompt
and we literally say something like,
"Hey, here's some additional instructions
this developer wanted you to know."
So that's something we preload.
But what we don't do in Claude
Code is when we start it up,
we don't take all the
files in the code base
and just like dump 'em
in the prompt and say
"Hey, here's all the files in
this code base, good luck."
Instead, we give Claude two
tools to basically just kind of
grab and find and search a
code base like you or I would.
And so we're thinking about ways
we can do progressive disclosure.
How do we kind of give
the model hints about,
okay, what information
might be available to it
and if it thinks it's
interested then it can go
and look things up and
figure out more about it.
Has anyone here about
heard about Skills? Yes.
So Skills is kind of
building on this pattern.
We saw this in Claude Code
where we could take files
that might be interesting at some point
and let the model kind of figure
out and use them over time
without having to load all
the information up front.
And so this is really what
Skills is under the hood.
So Skills is like this idea
where you as the end user
basically define, I don't
know, markdown files,
python files, things like that,
that might be useful for
the Agent at certain times.
So in claude.ai, a good
example of this is,
we want claude.ai to be
able to, I don't know,
make a PowerPoint or build a spreadsheet,
but we don't have to
take all the instructions
for making PowerPoints and
making good spreadsheets
and put it in the system
prompt all the time.
Instead in the system prompt,
we say something like,
"Hey, if the user asks
you to make a PowerPoint
or build a spreadsheet,
you go look in the Skills
folder and there's gonna be
a whole bunch of useful
stuff in there for you."
And so, in the 10% of
the time or whatever,
where the model where the end
user's gonna ask for this,
the model knows how to go
explore and get that information.
And then the last thing I wanna talk about
is long horizon tasks.
So remember we have this context
window that's gonna fill up
and remember that the
model is running in a loop.
API call, API call, API call,
and we don't wanna bust the prompt cache.
So that means we're not ever gonna
remove text from this conversation chain.
We're gonna be append only.
And so at some point our
conversation's gonna get too long
and we're gonna get to 200,000
tokens and what do we do?
Well, in Claude Code,
the way we solve for this is
something we call a compaction.
When Claude is getting
close to the context window,
we can detect this and what we do
is we basically inject a user message in
and the user message says
something along the lines of,
"Hey, I need to pass this
task off to another developer,
summarize everything
we were just working on
and all the important details."
And then we take that summary,
we clear out the whole conversation
so we start over fresh,
we put that summary at the
very start and then we say,
"Okay, keep working from here."
But there are other ways to solve this.
More experimental memory.
Can the model just write notes for itself?
And then also sub-Agent architectures.
So system prompts,
how do we get the instructions
in the right shape?
Tools, probably the most interesting
and useful things that the Agent can do.
Think about iterating on the tools.
Data retrieval, which we'll talk about.
How do we get the right information
to the Agent to do useful things?
And then being mindful of
long horizon optimizations,
if we're building an
Agent that's gonna work
for many minutes or hours.
- Awesome.
So I'm gonna dig into this kind of
data to retrieval challenge
and how do you curate context?
So if we kind of pause for a moment
and we think about human reasoning.
So, if you were to cross
a street, you know,
how many people would feel
comfortable crossing a street
based on essentially a snapshot
of where the cars were
on the street yesterday?
Like, most of us probably
wouldn't feel confident
about crossing that street.
And when it comes to human
reasoning and decision making,
you know, something as simple
as crossing the street,
obviously, we have a lot
of history of doing that.
Like I've probably crossed
the street successfully
tens of thousands of times in my life,
but I don't just rely on
my historical reference.
I also need, essentially,
a fresh representation
of what's happening in the moment.
So I need to pair essentially both
sort of real time signal information
of what's happening in the
moment, or fresh context,
with historical pattern
matching and so forth.
And this is true of most sort
of human reasoning situations,
but it's also true of
most operational use cases
when it comes to software,
you know, dealing with
customers and so forth.
So these are important
things to think about.
And this is, in many ways,
what the context problem is
when it comes to data retrieval,
because during this kind of online process
of prompt time assembly,
I need to go and gather
this contextual information.
And if my AI system is
doing something like
helping doctors or
nurses monitor patients,
I don't want that AI system
to be making decisions
based on vitals of the
patient from six hours ago.
I want it to be making decisions
based on what's happening
right now in this moment.
But that's a hard problem
in many businesses.
But there's a couple different ways
or two or three approaches
that I see businesses trying
to tackle this problem.
So the first thing is
essentially taking all of
their operational data stores,
whether it's the database, an API,
some sort SaaS application and
throwing MCP in front of it,
and I actually had a call
very early this morning
with a company that is
attempting this approach,
and it makes a lot of sense.
It's like let's take all of our
operational sources of truth
and we'll throw MCP on front of it
and we'll use tool calls into it,
and we'll get sort of
the latest information
about our business estate.
But in practice, there's a
number of challenges with this,
and it has nothing to do
with MCP, MCP's great,
but what you're doing
when you sort of open up
all your different locations
to a new workload like this
is you're adding a pretty
large security footprint
on these existing systems
that are probably all have their own ways
of governing access and access control.
So that's one problem you need to solve.
They're also probably serving
other workloads within your business.
So you're adding a bunch of
different new operational load
to these databases and other systems.
And probably one of the biggest challenges
is that none of these
systems were ever designed
with the idea that an AI
system was gonna use them.
They were designed for humans to use them.
So if I'm, you know, designing an API
and I'm an engineer that's
gonna do some integration
with that API, well I can
read the documentation,
I can read the API spec,
and I interpret it and
I write business logic
that allows me to use that API.
Maybe I'm only using a subset of the data
or I need to write code
to translate that data
into a different format.
Whatever it is, I can essentially,
I have the context to
understand that raw data,
but the model doesn't.
So what you need is not the raw data,
because the raw data
ends up with this problem
of exploding token costs
where we're feeding
a lot of information essentially
on the ingress in the model
and then leads to mistakes.
What you need is refined
data, or a dry data set.
It's like, we don't put
crude oil into a car.
The oil goes through a refinement process
before we feed a car and end up with fuel.
Or you know, we don't take
a bunch of raw ingredients
like you know, salt and pepper and spices
and a bunch of raw vegetables and so forth
and jam them in our mouths.
Maybe you do, I don't know, but,
usually you go through
some refinement process.
You cook it together in certain quantities
to derive a data set or
derive essentially a meal.
You goes through a refinement process.
The same thing needs to be applied
when you're building AI systems.
You need to essentially refine the data,
come up with curated data.
So once you realize that this problem,
where do you go to get derived data?
Well, there's a place
where many businesses
already create derived data sets
and that's typically in the lake house
or the data warehouse where
they're already taking
a bunch of their operational data,
they're sort of throwing it
left or right through ETL
into the lake house or the warehouse.
And then they might be going through like
a medallion architecture
of bronze, silver, gold,
and getting, defining a data product,
and that data product's used
to feed dashboards and so forth.
They can reverse ETL that out
to some operational database,
maybe throw MCP in front of that,
and then have their Agent talk to it.
So this solves the problem
of getting derived data,
but it introduces a new problem.
And the new problem is that
this is just too slow for
most operational use cases.
So it carries all of the same challenges
that ETL carries with it,
where you have different batch pipelines
delivering data at different stages,
you know, maybe it's 60
minutes, maybe it's once a day,
and you're combining
that data in some fashion
where it represents, essentially,
your data's only gonna be as
good as the slowest pipeline.
A lot of times that data is thrown raw,
so into the lake house,
and the data engineer
team has to figure out
how to reverse engineer and
understand what the scheme is,
the lineage and so forth.
Ends up with a lot of
reprocessing, remodeling,
and a bunch of cascading downsides.
But, we've been using this to essentially
feed dashboards and reports.
But it's a challenge when it comes
to trying to feed AI systems,
especially in the operational use case.
I mentioned patient monitoring.
There's very unlikely that
you'd be able to build a system
that goes through this process
that can monitor patients
at sort of the level
or the latency that you'd really want
to be able to make accurate decisions.
Similarly, if we take like
an example from airlines.
If I'm interfacing with
a customer service bot
that's powered by an AI Agent,
and I wanna rebook my flight,
well that Agent needs to know
what flights are available right now.
And in the, essentially
the foreseeable future,
can't make decisions based on a report
that was generated a day ago.
It also needs to know my
itinerary, my customer preference,
my preferences, maybe my status.
All this stuff needs to
be as fresh as possible.
So how do we sort of marry these worlds
of having both fresh
data and derived data?
That's really the key problem.
So we need a derived data set
that represents the current
state of the business,
and we can do that using a
combination of technologies.
So streaming data capture is really good
at essentially capturing
data as it's generated,
realtime data using technology
and tools like Kafka.
We can use stream processing,
in particular Apache Flink,
which helps you essentially
bring both sort of,
data at rest or batch data
together with realtime data
and just essentially batch data is just
bounded streams versus unbounded streams.
So we can combine that data in the stream
to create these dry data sets
using stream processing technology,
and then we need some
way of serving that data.
And ideally we have
one layer of governance
across all of this.
So at Confluent we've been
working on this problem
for a number of years
and a couple years ago
we launched a product called Tableflow,
which doesn't quite address this problem
but kind of starts to address
some of the challenges.
So Tableflow was designed
to try to bridge the gap
between the operational estate
and the analytics estate,
where we can do streaming data capture,
we can use stream processing
to clean the data,
sort of as close to
the source as possible,
create these derived data products
and then materialize that
data as iceberg tables
or delta lake tables directly
into your analytics platform
and kind of taking out the ETL process.
And this is great for
sort of bridging the gap
and it can also work both ways, where,
as you create data in
the analytics estate,
it also writes back out to Kafka
so you can serve your
operational use case as well,
but still a column restore is probably not
the right sort of data
layer for context serving.
So, what we launched a couple months ago
is what we called a
Real-Time Context Engine.
Where, as Tableflow,
you're taking a Kafka topic
and materializing as an iceberg
table or delta lake table.
With the Real-Time Context Engine,
what you're doing is you're
taking your Kafka topic
or your derived data set
and you're materializing
it as a fully managed
materialized table that's
managed by Confluent Cloud
and then is served as a tool over MCP.
So that way from data creation to serving
is very, very low latency,
and it's designed essentially
for feeding these AI systems.
And the AI system doesn't need
to be running on Confluent,
it could be running wherever
you want externally,
and it doesn't need to know anything
about the streaming architecture,
it's just talking MCP.
And this is one of the core components
of something that we call
Confluent Intelligence,
which we launched recently as well.
And the other two core components of that
is streaming Agents,
which allows you to build
event-driven Agents that are,
these aren't chat-based Agents,
these are essentially
system-triggered Agents
that react to data as it's being
generated within the stream.
And then also built in ML
functions or statistical models
for doing things like anomaly detection,
forecasting and fraud detection.
And all of this runs on Confluence
data streaming platforms.
So you can do your streaming data capture,
you can define these data products,
then you can materialize those
into your analytics systems
as well as power these
different AI systems
or streaming Agents
running on Confluent Cloud.
All right, so let's get
into a couple demos.
So I'm gonna walk through
two different demos.
The first one's pretty simple.
What we're gonna do is just show off
sort of how som some of these,
this concept of the Real-Time
Context Engine works.
So I'm gonna take a couple
different Kafka topics,
I'm gonna materialize them as tables
and then we're gonna use Claude Code
to talk to the MTP server
and I'll kind of walk through that.
So what we have here is
we have a Kafka topic
that represents customers.
We have orders that are being
made by those customers,
and then we're creating,
we're using Flink,
to combine those into an
enriched orders Kafka topic
and then we're serving
those as Tools over MTP.
And then we're gonna
essentially use Claude Code
as our MTP client to talk to it.
All right, so here on the
left we have Claude Code
and then there on the right
we have Confluent Cloud,
and you can see on Confluent Cloud
we're just looking at the
customer's Kafka topic
in a particular event that was created.
So the first thing I'm
gonna do, I'm gonna say,
ask to show me the topics
that I have access to.
So Claude's going to essentially reach out
and there's three
different tools available
within our MTP server.
One allows you to pull back the tables,
or essentially the topics
that are being materialized.
Here we have customers, we have
orders and enriched orders.
All of these have descriptions
so that MCP clients
and Claude can understand
what these actually mean.
And then we can ask for
details, in this case,
about the customer.
So we have table lookup,
essentially metadata or schema lookup
for these various tables.
And then we also have
essentially point in time lookup
so we can look up this
customer information
of Joe in this case.
So, pretty simple,
and you can see that matches
the information on the right.
Not, you know, groundbreaking.
You could probably do the
same thing with the database.
But the key here is that,
as we generate new data,
essentially it's
immediately reflected here.
So we will fully manage this
as new data gets generated,
it will automatically get
upserted and reindexed.
Or if you need to change
essentially the data model,
you can handle those kind of
reprocessing steps of batch up,
essentially completely remodeling the data
into a way that's actually
gonna serve your use case.
So we cleared the context here.
So now we're gonna say, show
me the last order placed.
In this case, it's gonna make
two different Tool calls.
It's gonna ask first for
what tables are available
'cause it needs to know
what tables are there,
and then it's gonna do
the point in time lookup
to pull in the orders
placed by this customer.
All right, so the next
thing we're gonna do
is we're gonna go over to Confluent Cloud
and we're gonna generate
a new event to update
this customer's email to show
how sort of updates work.
So we're gonna produce a new message,
but what you can imagine here is,
if you had some customer
profile page on a website,
I could go into that page,
update my email, click save,
that's gonna write as some
event into a Kafka topic
that I probably then do a database update
at some point as well.
But as I essentially
send in that new message,
behind the scenes, we're taking that data,
we're gonna upsert it into
the materialized table,
reindex the table, update the index,
and then that's immediately
available through MTP
for the AI Agent to consume.
So we're producing that message now.
You can see that it's a new message there.
And then once we go back over here,
we're just gonna clear the context
and ask to show the customer record again,
the details of the customer.
So there's really from it,
because this is all built on
the data streaming platform too
and sort of Kafka as the
basis for that, and Flink,
these are really designed
for really extreme high load
and low latency use cases.
So it doesn't matter how
complicated your data is
or how fast things are updating,
essentially you could combine
that in whatever way you want,
mix it however you want to
create these dry data sets,
and it's gonna be instantly
available to your AI systems.
So there we see the new email
and then we can continue to
do this to show, you know,
the latest enriched sort of
view of this data and so forth.
All right, so let's go
to the next use case.
So the next one is an application
for Robotaxi Customer Service.
Actually, before we came up here to talk,
we were talking about Waymos and Zoox
and all the autonomous drivers.
Well this is the next iteration of this,
this is River Robotaxis.
So these are like Waymos,
but for riverboats.
So imagine you're on the
Mississippi in New Orleans,
you pull up your River Robotaxi app
and you book essentially a riverboat.
That riverboat comes and picks you up.
So we're not gonna talk
about the fleet management.
What we're gonna talk about
is the customer service part of this.
So with the River Robotaxi,
there's gonna be different
spikes that happen
in terms of ride requests
and they need to take certain actions.
Maybe they need to dispatch
new boats to the area and so forth.
So what the scenario here is,
is that I've ordered a boat,
but it's taking longer
than expected to arrive.
I'm sure anybody's ever ridden
in an Uber, an Uber minute.
You know, one Uber minute
is really like five minutes.
It's very frustrating.
But so with this, what I
can do is I can go into
the River Robotaxi mobile app,
start a chat with customer service,
which is powered by an AI Agent,
and I want to know where is my boat?
What is taking so long?
So for in order for it
to be able to understand
and correctly contextualize response,
it needs to understand the ride requests,
the volume requests, what
decisions have been made.
Vehicle location telemetry
that's kind of streaming off
of these different
riverboats, customer profiles,
all need to be taken into account.
And what we're gonna do is essentially
use the context engine to serve
this data to the AI Agent,
which in this case was
built using LangGraph,
running on NAWS and
using Claude as a model.
All right, so let's cue that demo.
Little magic happening
behind the scenes here.
All right, there.
So this is our various Kafka topics here.
We have different topics
that we want to essentially
materialize through the context engine.
So we have completed actions
which represent decisions made
by Robotaxi for dealing with spikes
in ride requests and so forth.
And we're just gonna enable
the context engine for these.
And we can do the same
thing for ride requests.
Once we've done this,
these are immediately available
as these materialized tables
that can be consumed by our MCP.
I go over the River Support
and I ask about my ride.
On the left you can see the sort of
chain of thought reasoning
that Claude's going through
to get essentially the customer profile,
and then also get the
decision that was made
about why that there's a
delay going on right now.
It uses that to contextualize
a response back to the user,
letting them know that
they're aware of a delay,
they dispatched new boats
to the area to deal with it
and to please be patient.
But the only way it's able
to make a decision like that
or essentially be able to
create a response like that,
is it needs access to
that fresh contextual data
to be able to do it.
And this is again,
true for most of these kind
of operational use cases.
Oops, all right, what I
just said. Next steps.
All right, let's talk next steps here
before we get into questions.
So if this is of interest to you
and you wanna play around
with some of this stuff
you could check out our
Streaming Agents product.
You can also do,
there's a workshop that's
going on with this.
There's a quick start you can also use
if you wanna sort of
do the self-guided tour
and you can try this all out for free.
Using Confluent Cloud you get
$400 worth of free credits
for the first 30 days.
I'll pause for a minute
as people take pictures.
And the last thing here is just this week
we launched Confluent Marketplace,
which is a marketplace
for seeing all of these
various community connectors
and a whole bunch of other
community driven projects
that you can use within Confluence
Data Streaming Platform.
This allows you to ingest data
from pretty much anywhere,
any kind of source system
within the enterprise.
Really cool project.
And you can try that all
out for free as well.